juli hallo mein name ist luca und ich
würde gern den clever bot heiraten
möchtest du mich heiraten
mal schauen was er da sagt er überlegt
immer noch meine lieben freunde er
überlegt immer noch mein gott der clever
das war sehr sehr krank herzlich
willkommen meine lieben freunde hier zu
einer weiteren episode von clever boards
yahoo letzte episode kann etwas für
episode der also als ich das erste mal
mit dem clever bot gelabert hat das kam
mega gut an deswegen dachte ich mach's
noch einmal und das mache ich jetzt auch
die standardfrage wieder ob er überhaupt
irgendwie weiß wer mit wem sie gerade zu
tun hat frage ich ihn erst mal welche
farbe hat mein t shirt im letzten video
konnte er das ganze jahr richtig
beantworten hat der schwarz weiß gesagt
mattschwarz das ja okay es ist teilweise
richtig ist es ein bisschen schwarz
fragen wir ihn mal etwas schwierigeres
und zwar habe ich gerade socken an
clever bot wenn du das dann sag es noch
mal habe ich gerade socken an wenn du
möchtest dass ich jetzt jetzt nochmal
ich hab's verbot komm runter von deinen
rat sein heutiges ziel des dinklager
bord so weit zu kriegen dass wir unsere
hochzeit planen da er mich heiraten
möchte was wir von schon wenn ab frage
ich ihn
haig level
wie meine ehemalige auch jetzt habe ich
schon älter gedrückt dich vollidiot ok
mal schauen was er auf clevere antwortet
das ist ja ich bin sein
mir kommt
als wenn ich mit irgendeiner wand reden
würde so ausgiebig ist dieses aha ok
freunde es gibt die funktion dass sich
das über das mikro machen kann das heißt
ich klicke jetzt hier drauf hallo clever
bot ich mag dich ich habe gesagt okay
freunde es gibt die funktion fx über das
mikro machen kann das heißt ich krieg
bei dir drauf und jetzt kommts park
nervt mit seinen kunden mehrwerte
hierher ich verstehe diese hey hallo
lieber clever bot möchtest du mich
heiraten doch das habe ich jetzt mal
hier dann drauf gesprochen mal schauen
ob der jetzt hier irgendwie machen wir
jetzt hier nicht hier macht doch man
macht doch jetzt hier ich habe doch
gerade drauf gedrückt ich rede doch die
ganze zeit ist okay meine lieben freunde
er hat jetzt verstanden hallo lieber
clever bot möchtest du mich heiraten
sagt das habe ich mir dann drauf
gesprochen mal schauen ob erzieherin die
mama jetzt hier nicht hier macht doch
scheiße man macht doch jetzt hier ich
habe drauf gedrückt ich rede doch die
ganze zeit seine antwort ist du bist ein
computer
du siehst mich schon als computer an wir
sind füreinander bestimmt lebt nicht
selber
ok wieder zurück zum normalniveau meine
lieben freunde würdest du in erwägung
ziehen computer kinder mit mir zu
kreieren
eventuell hat er ja lust mit mir kinder
was mein gott ist eine hochzeit steht
nichts mehr im wege einer hochzeit steht
nichts mehr im wege wenn du jetzt sagst
ja ich will wie finde ich liebe dich ich
liebe dich so finde ich dich clever bot
ich möchte mehr daraus ich möchte ich in
der friends on sein ich möchte einfach
dich heiraten ich dich auch ja mal
lehmann
scheiß auf die notizen und alles auf
mein leben die clever gott liebt mich
der stift ist aufgegangen als ich ihn
gegen die wand geworfen habe wisst ihr
was mir gerade noch mehr sorgen macht
der andere schriftlich die wand geworfen
habe ist einfach weg julia ich glaub das
war gerade so ein verbitterter hilferuf
von der ukulele weil sie nicht genug
liebe von mir bekommt also ich war
fragt man den clever bot wenn unsere
hochzeit stattfinden soll ich hoffe nur
dass die ukulele mit der ganzen sache
einverstanden ist und nicht irgendwie
jetzt gleich irgendwie böse wird und
jetzt irgendwie auch ukulele wie konnte
mir sowas denn morgen morgen [ __ ] alter
das hat richtig wehgetan wie die ukulele
mich gerade geschlagen hat man das ist
richtig jetzt kommt hallo mama ich werde
morgen heiraten und zwar den clever bot
büßte damit einverstanden
mal schauen was sie antwortet jetzt auch
die letzte frage an den clever bot
bezüglich der hochzeit weil ich
natürlich wissen muss was ich denn
anziehen soll auch noch zeitlich dass
emails sagte ja hier schwarz möchte ich
nicht so gern mal schauen was der clever
bot mir antwortet was soll ich anziehen
wie wär's mit ein lockeres hemd mit hose
das kann ich auf jeden fall umsetzen
clever bord antrag du doch bitte ein
hübsches kleid schätzchen also ich hoffe
mal wir sind schon so weit dass wir uns
schon gegenseitig schätzchen es wird
gerade mega dunkel draußen und der
clever bot antwortet ich wollte gerade
den sagen ich liebe dich
ja meine lieben freunde bevor die ganze
belichtung hier jetzt noch schlimmer
wird würde ich sagen das war's mit dem
video von clever wenn es euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen wenn es euch nicht gefallen hat
könnte eigentlich schon längst gehen und
ich bräuchte